hi Matt well cheer for recent TV I'm at
Freedom Fest in Las Vegas and I am
joined today by economics professor
Edward Stringham who's got a really cool
title here is the Hackley endowed chair
for capitalism and free enterprise
studies at Fayetteville Fayetteville
State University welcome ed last time I
saw you if I'm not mistaken you were
busy kissing a Murray Rothbard book can
we get into some that that is true I do
a lot of interviews where I'm sitting in
the chair and they're asking me
questions about libertarianism and and
one of the things that they always get
around you you crazy people you don't
even want to have a police force so
you're one of the crazy people who
thinks that the government shouldn't
have a police force or at least was
interested in the idea tell us about
your crazy anarcho-capitalists well I
believe that we should have police but I
believe that we should have private
police as an alternative to government
police I think wherever we see
government it's not helpful its
bureaucratic it's not serving its
customers and I would say that
especially applies in the area of police
because police are so important I think
that we should abandon the idea that
government needs to provide I think this
is one of the prime candidates to have
private provision of and we actually
already see this in the current world
today so it's in one sense an abstract
idea a pie in the sky idea in another
sense it's not given that we have so
much private security and certain areas
actual full-fledged private police in
the United States today what's what's an
example of private police that we have
in the u.s. right now
well one great example is the patrol
Special Police in San Francisco they've
actually been around since the days of
the gold rush during the early years of
the gold rush there are basically no
government police so merchants decided
to hire their own private police they've
evolved over the years they're now in
the city charter of San Francisco and so
they've been basically in existence to
the entire history what they do up until
the 1990s they had full police powers
right now they
have been deprived of certain powers
that they used to have up until the last
couple decades but they will provide
extra services to merchants for example
who can't really rely on the government
police so if you have for example an
out-of-control person in your store
who's not being nice to your customers
that's actually considered a very low
priority event to government police so
if you call up the government police
they'll say okay maybe we'll get to it
if we have time if on the other hand you
call it the patrol special police you
have a private contractor they will come
right away and kindly escort the
gentleman to the door
doesn't this skew policing to those who
can afford it at the expense of those
who can't well I think the neat thing
about private policing is it's actually
available to all groups so there are
certain examples of very rich people
hiring private police - they want extra
security but there's also plenty of
examples in the world where poor people
have oftentimes self-help groups self
patrolling and they provide different
forms of security for themselves I think
if we were to look at any one group and
say who has miss served the most by
government police it would be low-income
people these people need private police
more than anybody now you've been making
this case for a while now do you see the
idea gaining traction are there you know
modified tiny versions of this what is
the kind of potential applicability of
it in the world that we live in right
now or are you working on changing idea
pathways first I I think both are good
good approaches I think we need to think
about the long run and the big
[ __ ] picture for sure and that's my
main interest but on the other hand even
in the world today there's examples
where it's been expanding private
security industry has just been
increasing by huge percentages over the
past few decades there's more private
security guards in the United States and
there are government police especially
right now we've got budgets government
budgets are going out of control the
pension systems are out of control
it's gonna reach a point where certain
places are going to be less and less
able governments are less and less able
to hire government police so there was a
town recently they just said ok we're
not going to have a police force in
North Carolina where I live they're
considering a bill right now which is
going to allow the private police
agencies North Carolina is another area
where they have special police private
police and they're considering a bill
right now that would allow the private
police to enforce laws on the properties
adjacent to their customers so these are
the types of things that are being
debated in the world today well that's
great thank you very much this
fascinating look within Stringham I am
Matt Welch for recent TV thank